WE'LL CALL THIS HEARING TO ORDER
THE ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE IS NOW CALLED THE
WATER.
WILL ESTABLISH A QUORUM MAPS
OKAY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FRAZIER HERE FONG. AGUIAR-CURRY.
ACRE THEIR BERMAN.
CHIU.
DALY HERE FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON.
HARPER PRESENT MATH CLASS.
MEDINA.
NAZARIAN.
O'DONNELL.
WE HAVE A QUORUM REMOVE ONE TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS MEASURES ON
CONSENT FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE ACR
TO. A TWO TWELVE FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO ACR TO TWENTY.
VOLUME FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
ACR TO TWENTY FOUR FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR ACR TO THIRTY.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE ACR TO
THIRTY SIX.
FILE ITEM.
NUMBER SIX FIVE S. B. FIVE GO TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN S. NINE A
THREE. FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT S.
B. NINE EIGHTY NINE FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE S. B..
TWELVE FIFTY NINE WITH ANY
MEMBER LIKE REMOVING ITEM FOR
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING NONE TO HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND.
WE HAVE LIKE A.
WE GOT.
WE THINK.
MATHIS.
SO IT IS FIRST BAGGARA CURRY
SECOND BY MISTER MATHIS BOUNCER
TO PLEASE HOLD OFF THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FRAZIER. FRAZIER AYE
FONG FONG AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BAKER.
BAKER I AM BERMAN.
CHIU.
DALY. DALY AYE FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN
AYE GIPSON.
HARPER.
HARPER I AM MATHIS.
MATHIS I MEDINA. MEDINA AYE THIS
ARYAN.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
SO HERE WE HAVE AN AUTHOR MISTER
BILL. SENTIMENT.
SICK CANCER THAT'S CONSENT
CALENDAR HAS TEN VOTES WE'VE
ROLLED IN FRANCE AND MEMBERS.
WELCOME CENTER.
MANY PROCEED ON SP THIRTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I'M READY TO
PROCEED.
YOUR WILL SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
TO SECURE MEMBERS.
AND.
THIS BILL S. B..
THIRTEEN TWENTY WAIT.
WHAT IT DOES?
IT'S SIMPLY EXTENSIVE SUNSET ON
THE ROAD YOU USE ITS CHARGE
TECHNICAL ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
FOR FOUR MORE YEARS.
AND ALLOWS IT TO CONTINUE
MEETING.
STUDY ALTERNATE MECHANISM FOR
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING SUCH AS
THE ROAD USE.
USAGE CHARGE SYSTEM.
THE COMMITTEE WAS CREATED IN
NOW.
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN BY THE
LEGISLATURE.
AND.
HAS A DIVERSE SET OF
STAKEHOLDERS
FROM ACROSS THE STREET.
ACROSS THE STATE TO.
OVERSEE A PILOT PROGRAM.
ON THE FIELD.
THANK YOU AN EXTENSIVE LIFE FOR
THIS COMMITTEE.
SO WE CAN HAVE.
THOUGH MORE RESEARCH IN THE
PUBLIC AND.
DELIVERED A PROCESS THANK YOU
FOR.
.
YOUR ATTENTION I REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO LIKE TO TEST.
MISTRUST YES SOMETHING THAT.
NOW MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS YES MARC
WATTS REPRESENTING
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA TODAY
WE WERE THE ORIGINAL SPONSORS
OF.
THE ORIGINAL LEGISLATION WERE
AND WE FIND THIS BILL TO BE.
IMPORTANT NEXT STEP FOR THE
PROGRAM. AND WE ARE DRIVER THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
IN THE REPRESENT PLEASE US
DEFAULT ON THE OF THE ELEMENT
CARE TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
MORE FOR THOMAS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA LIFE JOB SEARCH AND I
VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT THE
AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THEY LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OR SHARE THEIR
VIEWPOINT ON THE AUTHORS BILL.
SCENE NINE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OF
THE OTHER. THIS BIG.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I'M
JUST A COUPLE QUESTIONS SINCE
THIS IS THE EFFORT TO EXTEND
THAT PILOT PROJECT ESSENTIALLY
THAT'S BEEN IN PLACE FOR A FEW
YEARS.
AB HAVE YOU.
MADE I DIDN'T SEE ANY CHANGES TO
TRY TO ACCOUNT FOR.
EITHER A MORE REPRESENTATIVE
SAMPLE OF THE STATE IN TERMS OF
PARTICIPANTS BY DAM DEMOGRAPHICS
BY GEOGRAPHY BY INCOME LEVEL BY
USAGE THAT THEY MIGHT HAVE.
ALSO DIDN'T SEE CHANGES TO TRY
TO ACCOUNT FOR WHAT WE KNOW FROM
THE INITIAL STUDY IN THAT IS
THERE'S A LOT OF FREE RIDERS.
AND PEOPLE WHO ARE UNDER
REPORTING.
AB CAN YOU DRESS Y. IN EXTENDING
THE SUNSET THERE WE DIDN'T HEAR
NOT TAKING THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TRY TO.
ADOPT WHAT WOULD THEN BE A
CONTINUATION OF THE RESEARCH TO
REFLECT WHAT WE'VE LEARNED SO
FAR FROM THAT.
EFFORTS INCLUDING MAKING IT A
MUCH MORE DIVERSE AND REFLECTIVE
PULL OF PARTICIPANTS.
AND THEN CURRENTLY HAS.
AND THE.
UNDER REPORTING.
.
YES THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION.
WE CERTAINLY WOULD BE
RESPONSIVE TO ANY SUGGESTION.
FROM OUR YOU OR ANYBODY ELSE.
.
MADAM ASSEMBLY MEMBER IF WE
COULD.
.
GET YOUR SUGGESTS WERE CERTAINLY
WILLING TO CONSIDER THAT.
FOR EXPANDING THE COMMITTEE I
MEAN.
ARE THERE TWENTY VERY CONSIDERED
AN ERROR WHERE THEY NOT.
AND DECIDED AGAINST OR WITH
THEIRS ARE ANY PATEL THERE WAS
NO DECISION WAS SIMPLY TO EXTEND
THE BILL WAS TRYING TO BE AS
SIMPLE AS POSSIBLE JUST EXTEND
EXISTING.
ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
THEY CAME UP WITH A.
.
A REPORT ON THE PILOT PROGRAM.
PLAY VERY REPORT WHICH WE HAVE
HERE ANYBODY WOULD LIKE A IT
DOESN'T HAVE A COPY OF THE HAPPY
TO GIVE IT TO THEM.
.
AND.
WE'D BE HAPPY TO.
CONSIDER ANY ANY ADDITIONAL.
SUGGESTED YOU MIGHT HAVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU I THINK THOSE ARE
BEING THAT SOME OF THE
SUGGESTIONS IF THERE'S GOING TO
BE AN EXTENSION OF THIS.
FOR PURPOSES OF RESEARCH THAT
THAT IT YOU GET THE MOST USE OUT
OF IT WHICH IS IT'S NOT THE
CURRENT POOL OF PARTICIPANTS.
IS NOT PARTICULARLY REFLECTIVE
OF THOSE IN CALIFORNIA MAY BE
AFFECTED IF THEY'RE ULTIMATELY
IS A MILD GE MILEAGE FEAR
HOWEVER YOU WANT TO USE IT TERMS
OF THEIR INCOME LEVELS THEIR
USAGE OR GEOGRAPHY THERE.
OTHER DEMOGRAPHIC
CHARACTERISTICS.
THAT WOULD BE MAYBE A
POSSIBILITY AND THEN THE THE
NEED TO ADDRESS WHAT WE KNOW
FROM THE BAY AREA WITH RESPECT
TO THE HOT LANES AND OTHERWISE A
LOT OF PEOPLE JUST DON'T REPORT.
AND THAT ULTIMATELY AS ONE OF
THE ISSUES WITH ANY SYSTEM THAT
YOU'RE LEAVING A.
SORT OF AN HONOR SYSTEM FOR
HIGHER REPORTED AND THE RESEARCH
IS ONLY AS GOOD AS I'M THOSE
THOSE COMPONENTS EVERYTHING
THANKS FOR CONSIDERING US.
SO IS A MEMBER ALL JUST ADDRESS
THAT BECAUSE I DO SERVE ON THE
CDC WITH THE CHAIR OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE MISTER JIM IT OUT
FOR. AND THEY HAVE SEVERAL
PUBLIC MEETINGS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA EVERY YEAR SO YOUR
SUGGESTIONS COULD BE DONE AT A
PUBLIC MEETING UP PRIOR TO THIS
OR AFTER THIS IN WHICH WE WILL
BE ABLE TO. ADDRESS WITH THIS
EXTENDED SUNSET TO DO THE GOOD
WORK THAT THEY'RE DOING. THERE'S
JUST SO MUCH TO COMPILE AT THIS
POINT TIME YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
IT THE RIGHT WAY WITHOUT A BIG.
.
BIG BROTHER KIND OF ASPECT SO
AGAIN YOU YOUR HER CONCERNS ARE
WELL NOTED BUT YOU CAN ADDRESS
ACOSTA COMMISSIONER COMMITTEE
OF.
UP FRONT ANYTIME YOU WANT THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN INVITATIONAL
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF MY
CONSTITUENTS RIGHT NOW AT THIS
PUBLIC MEETING PUTTING THAT. FOR
THOSE OF YOU MIGHT MY
SUGGESTIONS THANK YOU.
THE OTHER QUESTIONS OF THE.
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
CENTER WAS LIKE A CLOSE.
THANK YOU ARE BE MORE HAPPY TO
CONVEY THOSE SUGGESTIONS AND
URGENT AYE VOTE.
Q..
.
AS I STATED BEFORE SERVING WITH
MR MEANT AFTER HE'S BEEN KEEPING
ME APPRISED OF THE UP PROGRESS.
AND ALL OF THE.
.
COMPLEXITIES AGO ALONG WITH THIS
AGAIN. IT WILL BE THE PROBABLY
THE MOST.
USEFUL AND FAIR WAY OF DOING
THINGS WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
FUNDING ROADS GOING DOWN.
WITH THE.
ADVENT OF ELECTRIC VEHICLES ONE
NOT SO.
LOOK FORWARD TO OF THE
EXTENSION OF THIS AND OF
COMMITTEE BEING SUCCESSFUL MEANT
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WE HAVE A FIRST BY AGREE
ACCURATE CURRY SECOND BY IN THIS
AREA.
I'M SECTOR PLEASE CALL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER IPHONE. THONG NO
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BAKER NO BAKER NO
BERMAN. BERMAN AYE CHU. CHU AYE
DALY. DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
HARPER.
HARPER NO MATHIS.
MATHIS NO MEDINA. MEDINA AYE IN
THIS AREA. NAZARIAN AYE
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
IT'S NINE TO FOUR VOTES OUT IF
WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
A COUPLE MINUTES PREZZO MEMBERS
THANK YOU SENATOR.
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS WILL LEAVE
AND I WILL GO AHEAD AND LIFT THE
CALL FOR THE.
CONSENT.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR CURRENT
VOTE IS TEN TO ZERO BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE CHU. CHU AYE GIPSON
AYE GIPSON AYE IN THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE FINAL VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
FOURTEEN TO ZERO.
FILE ITEM TEN SP THIRTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT CURRENT VOTERS NINE TO
FOUR GIPSON HI GIPSON I AND
FINAL VOTE TEND TO FOR
.
THIS.
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS FOR THE
ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE IS NOW COMPLETE THIS
HEARING IS ADJOURNED